cette année 2022 sera consacrée à la
jeunesse parce que durant cette phase de
pandémie les jeunes ont fait preuve de
solidarité
intergénérationnelle sans précédent pour
protéger les plus âgés ils ont mis entre
parenthèses leurs études leur vie
professionnelle leur vie sociale
amoureuse la fête il était bien légitime
que les institutions l'union européenne
en l'occurrence leur consacre cette
année pour leur dire qu'elle pensait à
eux qu'elle était consciente des efforts
et qu'elle devait faire plus les jeunes
ont été les premiers touchés par le
chômage 17 % au niveau européen le
chômage a progressé de +2 points pendant
la période de pandémie alors que c'était
de -2 1% pour l'ensemble de la
population donc on le voit il ya un
effort majeur à faire sur ce plan
deuxième sujet la santé mentale
l'isolément a créé des vraies situations
de détresse pour les jeunes quand on
coupe le lien social on est plus
vulnérable donc sur tous ces sujets
l'union européenne va agir l'année
européenne de la jeunesse ça va être des
référents nationaux dans tous les états
membres qui vont devoir organiser
rassembler et surtout agir sur les
fronts prioritaires que sont l'emploi
l'accès à l'information pour tous la
réformation même quand parce qu'on est
jeune longtemps mais aussi sur le plan
de l'accès à la santé et pour la santé
mentale des jeunes et puis bien sûr il
ya un volet dédié à la culture le
partage culturel est très important pour
créer l'europe à la fête aussi tout
simplement il faut des grands événements
qui rassemblait 10 févr